[Musica]
vi voglio tutti in questa posizione
anche attraverso lo schermo
ora controlliamo un muscolo e diciamo
sono forte e rilascia sono forte e
rilasci bene adesso facciamo la stessa
cosa ma rendiamo la contrazione con uno
shock come una scossa elettrica con la
stessa potenza di un pugno di bruxelles
pronti facciamo il muscolo muscolo
muscolo muscolo contrae ok ora facciamo
la stessa cosa sulla musica prima 20 e
poi veloci proviamo tutte velocità
[Musica]
perfetto
ricordate quello che abbiamo appena
fatto ci tornerà utile guidati ora cosa
vedete qui questa è l'immagine nella mia
mente diversi anni fa ma facciamo un
passo indietro
mio nonno soffriva di parkinson
quando penso a lui non ho mai
un'immagine ferma è sempre in movimento
mio nonno mi ha insegnato con l'esempio
giorno dopo giorno che le circostanze
non definivano la sua identità in questo
caso la malattia che cosa voglio dire
con questo quando penso a mio nonno
penso a un rispettato avvocato ha un
ottimo marito un nono
fantastico no a un malato a un paziente
a un mangia pillole e lui di pillon
esempi che mangiava parecchie questo
sono io a 10 anni ho scoperto la danza
per caso e grazie alla danza
ho scoperto la cultura hip hop quello
che più mi ha colpito di questo nuovo
mondo di questo nuovo diverso è il
potere di cambiare il punto di vista e
la libertà di scegliersi l'identità
storicamente negli anni 70 i ragazzini
nel south bronx a new york che hanno
sostanzialmente creato questa cultura
vivevano una realtà fatta di degrado
povertà droga violenza razzismo
e nonostante ciò non hanno lasciato che
le circostanze definissero la loro
identità e questo è un concetto chiave
che toccava le corde giuste con me e voi
magari vi starete chiedendo perché un
ragazzino bianco italiano di genova quei
capelli arancioni privilegiato che viene
da una famiglia di avvocati e forze
dell'ordine perché una persona così si
avvicina a una cultura nata
cinquant'anni prima in un altro
continente creata da persone di colore
che avevano come loro realtà povertà
degrado sofferenza droga razzismo
semplice sono nato con una malattia rara
chiamata estrofia vescicale che
degenerativa e non ha cura per lo stato
italiano
sono 100 per cento disabile ed è solo
grazie all'i pod io ho trovato la forza
e non lasciare che le circostanze in
questo caso la malattia definissero la
mia dedita non volevo essere il disabile
volevo essere simon e un'anima danzante
tra tutti gli stili di danza inclusi
nella cultura hip hop quello che più mi
ha colpito da subito è stato il pop ed
ancora ricordo il primo giorno in cui ho
visto qualcuno di fronte a me e ballare
popping sembrava che la terra tremasse
ma che cos'è il pop e non vi starete
chiedendo
bene vi ricordate quello che abbiamo
fatto all'inizio e il muscolo sulla
musica bene quello è il pop
la tecnica base di questa danza da
italiano l'immagine migliore che io vi
possa dare per spiegarvi
che cos'è il pop ed è pasta e sugo la
pasta è il movimento
la reazione naturale alla musica esso è
la contrazione forte di tutti i muscoli
del corpo tempo a ritmo di musica e da
buoni italiani vogliano tanta pasta e
tanto sua pubblica da ragazzino facevo
questo sempre costantemente tutto il
giorno a tutti i giorni tanto che mia
mamma mia nonna i miei amici mi dicevano
sempre simone pasta tremare e io dicevo
ma non sto tremando sto danzando tremare
qui è la parola chiave quella che ha
sbloccato l'immagine nella mia mente la
stessa immagine che vi ho mostrato
all'inizio le persone con parkinson
tremano senza musica le persone che
fanno popping tremano sulla musica
questa è stata la scintilla il punto di
partenza che mi ha fatto realizzare che
voleva unire queste due realtà volevo
supportare le persone affette da
parkinson attraverso lo studio della
danza potter remixando il concetto
stesso di disabilità portando umanità
laddove si è persa a causa di una
malattia danno la forza alle persone di
non lasciare che le circostanze
definiscano la nuova identità la stessa
forza che hip hop alla tua mente da
ragazzino
volevo trasformare il tremore in pop una
sfortuna in un punto di partenza
in un superpotere
[Musica]
l'impatto di questo cambio di punto di
vista di questo cambio di prospettiva è
enorme
a volte quasi magico un mio studente di
new york
una volta mi scrisse mi disse sento che
queste lezioni di danza mi stanno
ridando un controllo del corpo che avevo
perso da anni a causa del parkinson
per non parlare poi dei guano dei miei
nipoti che dicono quando mi vedono
danzare questo è ciò che mi spinge ad
andare avanti questo tipo di impatto
molti dei miei studenti spesso entrano
in sala entro la lezione meglio dire con
parecchie difficoltà con le stampelle
con dolori fisici delle problematiche
visibili reali concrete entrano lezione
parte la musica tutti pensiamo ci
alleniamo studiamo e ci divertiamo
finisce la lezione e spesso devo
rincorrere gli studenti con le stampelle
che loro dimenticano nello studio questo
tipo di impatto è veramente così forte
che sembra magia e sempre parlando di
impatto
volevo remixare il concetto di
disabilità perché dico questo
il parkinson come malattia ha un vero
impatto sulle persone sia sulle persone
che soffrono sia sulle persone attorno
al sistema il parkinson può cambiare il
modo in cui parli in cui ti vesti in cui
cammini la tua autostima
il cerchio di amici e familiari bene io
volevo cambiare questo
rai mixarlo e sostituire la parola
parkinson la parola hip hop le pop
cambia come parli come ti vesti come
cammini l'autostima il cerchio di amici
e familiari
questo è il tipo di impatto che volevo
portare alle persone ma l'impatto più
grande forse io lo vedo attraverso il
sorriso le persone con parkinson spesso
hanno difficoltà a mostrare le proprie
emozioni tramite espressioni facciali
proprio a causa del parkinson a fine
lezione se sorridono all'esterno
vuol dire che all'interno stanno
esplodendo di gioia
[Musica]
no
io sono di genova e da buon genovese
sono molto diffidente e penso sempre al
caso peggiore perché dico questo perché
voglio fare una piccola riflessione
cosa succede quando si partecipa a una
delle mie lezione di danza nel caso
migliore trasformi un sintomo in un
superpotere trasformi la negatività in
positività attraverso l'espressione
artistica ma nel caso peggiore quello
che penso subito io comunque fi attività
fisica per un'ora che comunque fa bene
inoltre le mie lezioni di danza sono
gratuite per i partecipanti perché non
vogliono creare sulla disabilità perciò
se partecipi ci guadagni se danzi ti
migliori stabilità e per me fantastico
portare avanti questo progetto
questa realtà no profit perché riesco a
condividere le mie passioni e i miei
valori con le persone attorno a me
facendo quello che amo di più quindi
vinciamo tutti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
per concludere trasformate il vostro
negativo in su per poter ha supportato e
chi lo fa e condividete il fuoco della
vostra passione con più persone
possibili soprattutto quelle che
potrebbero beneficiarne di più e se in
certi momenti non vi sentirete pronti
ricordatevi di dire a voi stessi
sono forte
[Applauso]